help is coming for local business owners
navigating the necessary paperwork to
request
stimulus package funding the nevada
business advisors
expanding its lender network by
partnering with first bank of the lake
a community-based lender in missouri
nevada business advisors
now able to offer businesses in nevada
and throughout the u.s
an opportunity to apply for the second
draw of the program
before the portal opens to all banks and
lenders last time businesses weren't
able to secure funding for a variety of
reasons last year what we found
is a lot of the banks and lenders
stopped taking applications because they
were just over flooded right
and and then you had some businesses
that didn't have a banking relationship
that we're just not able to apply or
we're giving wrong information coburn
says this time around
sba has made an effort to concentrate on
minority and women-owned businesses
first because they found a number of
them didn't get the funding last year
for more information visit our website
8newsnow.com